[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose and host of the ken coleman
show is my co-host today as we talk
about your relationships your careers
your jobs your work your money and your
life it's what we do here at ramsey we
talk to you about all of these things
and we're gonna talk to you about them
right in front of you open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the call is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it greg is with us in frederick maryland
to start off this hour hi greg welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave um how's everything going i
know ask you how you're doing but you
like me are better than we need to be
right that's exactly right sir what's up
yes uh i have a question for you i've
been pondering this to uh exactly what i
should do um i'm retired been retired
for a couple years
financially gotta bless us
uh i have one portfolio
that i've been saving over the years to
pay the house off we have a
house that we've got about 80 000 left
and i can take that money
pay it off
or continue to pay the the monthly
premium so my question to you dave is
what
should i do should i worry about the
bite i'm going to get from taxes but the
comfort and relief i have of owning my
house
i'm 71 so i'm on the end of the
investment
spectrum yeah so how much what's your
total nest egg
well counting the house everything no
your total nest egg in your retirement
accounts or in your
stock portfolios or whatever
about 800 give or take been on the
market okay
so um you know enough to you knew enough
about me to be able to know how i was
going to answer the question how are you
doing
so you already know i'm going to answer
this
okay don't you
i think i do but i'm not positive that's
okay well i'm calling that's okay okay
if you had eighty thousand dollars to
your name
i would question whether you pay off
your house or not because i don't want
you to be broke with a paid off house
okay yeah well you got 800 000 and you
use 80 grand to pay off the house
i think you're still going to be okay
so i pay off my house about two years
ago
right
actually you know we've had a financial
advisor most of our lives actually
getting ready to go talk to one of your
recommendations here next week okay
about switching okay
but why are you switching well because
i've been listening to you and i you
raised a good point
and i always knew it but never really
followed through with it as far as it's
my money
they should be teaching me and the guy
that we have we've been making good
money with them for years but
looking back on it it's like well i've
made recommendations you know why aren't
you taking them or at least telling me
what's going on
so i'm thinking is i'm not okay so he's
a bit arrogant and a bit controlling is
and you want to be away from that is
that what you're saying
i would say to some extent yeah yeah
that's probably true you know
a lot of people in that business are so
that's not that unusual it's kind of one
of the ways that those of us that come
out of that business are taught or
taught to drop the glasses down on the
end of our nose and talk down to you
and you're the one that's a millionaire
[Laughter]
well i i'm upset because i didn't find
out about you
20 years ago but be that as it may um i
got you now and i just uh need your
input um you know
i take a big hit on taxes because you're
not going to take a big hit on taxes
you're going to take a little hit on
taxes pay off your house today
thanks for your call man i appreciate
you listening we're honored to have you
it's uh ken it's just essential that in
any area of our lives career coaching um
even what dr dalony does even with
therapy so to speak that the person
you're involved with
is not dropping their glasses on the end
of their nose that's right yeah it's you
said it for years
the heart of the teacher you know when
we talk about our smart investor pros
we're all we've told people go sit with
multiple interview them because we want
them to have the heart of the teacher
not just in how they treat you but more
importantly that they will teach you
until you get it because it is your
money we don't want somebody telling me
what to do we want someone going okay
here's where we see a strategy whether
it be mental health or in your job and
trying to grow professionally it's
always good to have a coach but a coach
who doesn't just tell you what to do but
shows you how to do it there's a big
difference and you know you understand
why and what yeah
not just follow my directions without
thinking yeah um yeah we just you don't
want to be sheeple
that's right that's right you don't want
to be in any area of your life because
it's not going to end well for you so i
question everything until you give me a
reason not to that's right do i
understand why we're doing this and it's
okay by the way to keep asking why
uh you know what else is interesting too
is the psychology behind greg's call and
i actually totally see myself
in that call in that i hate taxes so
much
and for good reason and greg
also has great reasons
but in that case it's like the taxes you
got to pay them and so don't don't miss
out on the bigger
play the bigger wealth building the
bigger benefit of paying the house off
because we hate that tax
burden we hate that oh i got to pay that
i get that i certainly see that
yeah well
and here's the thing at 70 and a half
you have to begin pulling money out
systematically anyway that's right
you're required minimum distributions
and so um you don't have a choice it's
not enough to pay off the house but
you're going to have some taxes anyway
yeah you got to deal with that that's uh
if you've got everything in traditional
or whatever you've got in traditional is
going to have to begin to systematically
be moved out and so yeah but i agree
i've
found myself doing things for tax
reasons only if i'm not careful and
they're not good economic
reasons but they're good tax reasons
that's right and boy that just that just
comes from this whole thing of hating
taxes and hating how stupidly the
government handles our money that's
right so on
open phones here at triple a eight two
five five two two five
bethany on instagram says i wanna break
out on my own and do my own thing before
i turn 30 but i'm not sure yet what i
want to do and how to figure it out can
you give me a little advice ken yeah so
what we want to do is we want to look at
the easiest
way to find clues to this big question
what do i want to do with my life and we
start with talent dave we're all given
talent by our creator
and he gave us these talents to use
and and and what we can do is begin to
say wait a second these are the areas
and let's just think of hard skills and
soft skills and you can start if you're
having a hard time identifying them for
yourself number one there's nothing
wrong with you
but there are others in our lives people
who have coached us people who have
taught us people who have done life with
us that can help us see ourselves as the
world seizes so what do you really do
well it's always come easy for you this
is the idea of talent we can take talent
and then with practice and diligence and
training turn it into a skill so think
of it a power tool
start with talent because when we know
we're good at it then we begin to ask
the question i'm good at this how can i
use this to do something i really enjoy
then we begin to say what makes me come
alive what do i enjoy when i do this
type of task see i was in class i always
got in trouble for talking
well it's a good thing
i invented talk radio
you love communicating and so just look
at those clues but first greater
audience is going hey i got the same
question
go to ramsay solutions and get the get
clear career assessment 20 minutes or
less you're going to get more answers
than you've ever had in your life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
over the last 30 years i've walked with
tens of thousands of people and their
families to help them overcome their
stresses
and we found that money stress is just
one of all kinds of ways we experience
stress people struggle with stress
anxiety loneliness all the time
we all have some sort of crazy
out there right we've all had lies told
about us by well-meaning people or not
so well-meaning people and the list
hurts
list of hurts they go on and on
unfortunately you can't change your past
but you can change your future and
here's the great news dr john deloney
has a brand new book out we are putting
it in pre-sale yesterday and it sold a
record number is doing very well
called own your past change your future
he'll walk you through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness through his
personal stories decades of experience
and research dr deloney shows us how to
transform hurt
into healing and move from hopelessness
to hope fullness
it's available for pre-order right now
uh he'll show you how to deal with
different kinds of trauma how to get
connected to a community and make
friends as an adult
and the steps you could take to change
your thoughts and actions it's possible
and here's why you need to pre-order
you're going to get over 300 dollars
worth of bonus items with a pre-order
which includes an entire month free
of one-on-one counseling with better
help one of dr dolone's sponsors so
pre-order your copy of own your past
change your future for only 20 dollars
get 300 worth of stuff do it at
ramseysolutions.com and do it
today dr john's book came out of the
shoot hot ken yeah well i mean a lot of
pain out there and we're seeing that and
it's only been you know exacerbated by a
two-year period of tremendous
uncertainty
changing the
rhythms and the locations of how we
interact with people you mentioned this
in staff meeting monday you know we just
we think there's going to be a real
revolution was the word you used you
know of people returning to the
humanness and you know we're relational
human beings and when that's broken when
it's uh when it's been changed i mean
it's just a lot of pain out there it's
the right time for this yep it's needed
very needed sunny is with us in dallas
texas hi sonny welcome to the ramsey
show how can we help
hey guys how y'all doing today thank you
for taking my call um i'm just real
brief i'm 27 years old my wife is 27 as
well we have three kids that are all
under the age of five
um we're just we're stuck i mean living
paycheck to paycheck i work in the oil
field and
luckily now i'm in the position where
they're trying to train me up to a
higher position with better pay
uh my wife is a uh she just took a job
of being a christian principal at a
christian school
um what do you guys remember a pretty
significant pay cut
no more than probably about 60 70 000 a
year
that was pretty vague you don't know
what you make
i mean from working in the oil field out
here it it
it fluctuates quite always
okay all right so what is your why did
your wife take a significant pay cut if
you have money problems
the church the church is real small and
the christian academy that she became
the principal
at is very small as well she's working
to get more students in why did she take
a pay cut
why did she take a job
when you all are broke that it was a pay
cut
from our discussions she said it felt
like it was god's calling
i mean we're we're very strong in our
faith and
i mean anytime god calls on us i mean
we we jump to it what was she doing
before she moved into this role
she was a assistant director at the boys
and girls club making about 20 000 here
and now she's making less than 20 000.
she makes about 600 every two
weeks take home about 550 after texas
well
does she feel called into education or
christian education specifically
christian education
well i want to challenge an assumption
here that that's the only way she can do
that i certainly understand the passion
here
uh but but but this has financial
implications to it so listen we're both
strong in our faith too and we believe
god calls you things just like you guys
do yeah but let me tell you what
he also says you need to take care of
your own household first or you're worse
than an unbeliever he doesn't call you
to do things that are perpendicular to
scripture
yes sir and so i'm i'm i'm gonna
challenge that straight up i mean i'm
not saying she needs to go quit her job
but you can't just throw the god card
down on something that mathematically
doesn't work and that all of a sudden
makes it work
um
sometimes sometimes god tells us to do
that i'm i'm open to that idea but
that's the exception rather than the
rule
in the way that he interacts with us
um and that's me walking with him for 50
years so uh anyway all right so now you
guys have got a 60 70 000 income and
you're living paycheck to paycheck and
you're sick of that and you're getting a
raise you think on the oil field
yes sir how much your raise gonna be
uh i could i'm right now i'm making 20
an hour and i could be jumping up to
anywhere from 75 to 85 000 a year i'll
be put on salary well that'd make a lot
of difference
yes it would because i'd put you guys at
100k instead of 70k
yes sir yeehaw okay so how much debt do
you have how
um
combined with the vehicle it's probably
about maybe 30 000. and with the vehicle
how much is the vehicle debt
uh about
17 18k okay all right
well what we'll do is i'm going to put
you guys into uh financial peace
university in ramsey plus okay
i want you to go through the class do
what
i said thank you sir sure we're going to
pay for it because i've been broke and
and scared and not knowing what to do
just like you guys are i know how it
feels
so i want you guys to get in there and
get on the written budget on the every
dollar app and both of you working
together on that app i want you to
attack this debt with every dollar you
can squeeze out of your life no eating
out no vacations you're broke people
you got to get out of not being broke
people before you start goofing off with
money again and we're going to get you
out because it's not a forever thing and
it doesn't necessarily depend on your
raise but your raise will help
yes sir okay so we're not going out to
eat we're not going on vacations and if
you can't turn the corner pretty quick
on doing the budget and start actually
making some progress paying off some of
your smaller debts you may need to sell
that car
i don't think you do though
i think you guys getting in control and
working together and sacrificing and
having a written plan which will make
you feel like you've got a raise i think
you can turn the corner with what you
got without selling the car but if you
have to sell the car to get where you
can balance this out
her job pay cut may have cost you the
car
yes sir it may mean you can't afford it
i don't think so though i think you can
make it
and i want you guys to slow down um
and look at the total picture of your
life
when god starts calling you to something
and and is he calling you to a specific
thing like that particular school or is
he calling you to christian ed instead
of boys or girls club or is he calling
you to help out over at the a church
where you go that's a small church and
really can't afford a principal because
they're not paying a principal enough to
stay above the poverty level
uh so maybe they need to have a lay
person that's a volunteer and your wife
does this as her volunteer ministry on
the side while she keeps her other job
or a different job that's another way
you guys could have gotten at fulfilling
that same burden that the holy spirit
was putting on her and i'm not doubting
the that god spoke to you guys about
this i'm just doubting the way it's
played out and the timing of it uh
because it's left you guys in a lurch
and my heavenly father is crazy about me
and he doesn't lead me into a canyon to
get killed
yeah i i think there's a couple things i
would look at seasons
if she were she's got a commitment now
so if there's two or three months left
in the school year i don't know what it
is in texas but she can fulfill her
commitment but also find a christian
education job that pays
way more than what she's getting which i
think is about 1200 a month which will
help you all and then there may be a
season of life where she does work for
way less as a true ministry but that may
be a season much further down the road i
think you gotta really discern and
really look into that situation i i you
know be careful how you bring it up to
her you want to honor her heart but also
go hey what are some other options to do
what you feel called to do but also
allow us to thrive financially because
it's there
it's definitely there yep
absolutely it can just be timing it can
be process it can be structure
and you still fulfill the calling
within the gut within a little bit of
different guidelines instead of an all
or nothing thing but for today you're
there so here's how we're going to help
you hang on kelly's going to help you
sign up we're going to walk with you on
this and want to see how god plays his
hand
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage dennis and christy are
with us hey guys how are you doing well
how are you
welcome welcome where do you guys live
madison alabama oh down next to
huntsville yes just down the road a
little ways here
so welcome to nashville thank you and uh
apparently you're a house divided with
an auburn fan and an alabama united as
united house united what are you united
in football exactly yeah we watch each
other's teams play and when they play
each other we don't hold it against each
other if they if his team wins i don't
and if my team wins he doesn't hold it
against me so oh she's happy i'm happy
then you know as an alabama our auburn
fan goes they're pretty sweet people
yeah
yeah thank you
yeah we try to maturity as well you guys
they're going to just sell yeah i just i
don't know i mean that's i don't know if
that would work you're saying no trash
talk at all during the game or before
the game well very little oh yeah
every now and then when we first got
married there was a lot more of it but
we've gotten more accustomed to reading
each other's teams on so there you go
you guys are great thank you that's
unusual i love it so how much debt have
you guys paid off ninety few thousand
ninety two thousand how long did that
take over seven years good for you and
your range of income during that seven
years 90 to 120 90 to 120. what do you
guys do for a living i'm a software
engineer
i'm a homemaker all right very good what
kind of debt was the 92 000
all house paid off your house
yes look at that weird people
i love it way to go you two
very good excellent job what's that
house worth
uh right now according to zillow as
accurate as that can be uh 287. all
right very good how does that feel have
i paid for everything excellent
today we paid it off we went walking in
the backyard and yes it does feel
different you took it yeah you did what
i said you walk through the backyard
with no shoes the grass feels different
when it's yours it does absolutely
yep that's good way to go you guys so
what started you on this journey seven
years ago tell us the story well i was
uh
had a car repair that needed to be done
and they're telling me it needs some
maintenance
but it was like after christmas had some
credit cards at the time
and i just realized that uh i told him i
couldn't really afford it and that's
just told me that i was doing things
wrong that's when i looked in to
ever got your book credit and realized
that yeah there is a better way to do
things oh wow okay so christy he comes
home and goes okay we can't fix the car
i'm reading i'm gonna read a book i'm
we're done with this what'd you say
i actually
was before we got married i was in debt
as well and
about a third of the debt was late
charges and over limit fees
and sometimes over limit fees would then
push me into having late charges because
i couldn't afford to pay
what the minimum was they wanted me to
pay so i was on board
i've been there so you're saying you
were sick of that too oh yes so whatever
we got to do we got to do and you sat
down together started putting the plan
together absolutely wow so impressive
and here you stand seven years later
with a paid off house yes wow
way to go thank you so how long did it
take to begin to you saw momentum you're
reading this book
right and you're going okay i'm reading
and i'm beginning to make some changes
do you remember back when it began to
catch holding you both you're going okay
not only do we agree with it but now
we're seeing this and we get excited
it's about six months six months yeah
yeah that's when we started saying the
balance is going down further
yeah
and you get control you get a sense of
power over the money over the numbers
yeah good for you guys i'm so proud of
you
very very well done what was the hardest
part of this process for you
um for me i think it was he is very much
the budgeting nerd in our family and
there were times that i was impatient
and wanting to
buy things and he's very
stick with the budget it's it's not in
the budget we don't have the money you
know so you're telling me that a
software engineer might be a little bit
nerdy and stressed
absolutely yeah he's pretty much
somewhere here you know
but but here's something and sometimes
it was just a hundred or two dollars
worth of maybe like a storm door or
things like that but he was he's very
much
okay well here's the rules follow the
rules yes he's very by the book i like
it doctor no huh he said no
but then finally there were some things
he said oh i didn't realize how
inexpensive this was and then if we had
it in the budget
left over then we could do it then we
did it so that works just had to build
the plan yeah the plan build the plan
work the plan build up that's the
software yeah that's why oh yeah that's
why you're successful i like it build
the plan work the plan
all right what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is build a
plan work the plan what else that's it
uh
steve stay away from debt to
be intentional with your money
you know plan your impulses
stay focused yeah
plan your impulses that's a good word
what does that mean
well you can be just plan you know when
you
want to just buy something just make
sure you have enough like
a line item in your budget for
impulsive spending yeah nice so you take
the impulse out of impulse well you feel
that we want it but then you put a plan
in place that's pretty good yeah you
plan even like vacations and
different things you know try to build
them as much as you can into the plan
although some things that are unplanned
do come up but you do your best to try
to
make sure that each
item in your budget has a monetary
amount if it's within your income yeah
way to go you guys i'm so proud of you
who cheered you on the most outside the
two of you
family yeah okay so your family knew
what you were working on and they said
go get them exactly good very cool very
good good job y'all well we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires and
that's definitely the next
chapter in your story you're going to
move on to that if you hadn't already
you might be there already yeah and uh
well i'm sorry we are oh you did it all
right yes
i talked to you before in 2019 i just
barely crossed
the line
and then a pandemic happened the
pestilence
and yeah i dropped out of it and then
came in after that fall
back with a vengeance okay all right so
your investments are up over 700 000
then yeah with a 300 000 paid for house
touchdown there it is how old are you
guys
i turned 53 days ago all right i'm 56.
all right you're the perfect baby steps
millionaires well done thank you
how much of this money did you inherit
uh we had the ten thousand from a uh
inheritance ten thousand yeah i don't
think you're millionaires because of
that well i think you're millionaires
because of the people i'm looking at in
front of me they're the secret sauce in
that equation well we'll give you a copy
of that you'll read about the equivalent
of yourself in there as you go along
well done and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away and get
somebody else disrupted and get them
moving along like they need to so very
well done dennis and christy from
madison alabama 92 000 paid off in seven
years making 90 to 120 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
where did three
[Applause]
that's how it's done
and so there let that be a lesson to you
if you want to be a millionaire be nice
to your spouse about opposing football
teams yeah i mean i think that's a key
thing that had to be some that factor
about them had to had to really help in
the debt-free journey too getting on the
same page about a budget if you can get
along during an alabama auburn iron i
know family members that haven't spoken
in years
that are opposition because the kid
chose to go to the wrong school i mean i
that's a hateful sense that's a hateful
thing yeah it's just a
you know i don't know of another
in-state rivalry around here anyway
that's
quite as rough and tough as that one is
and they're just so sweet yeah they're
sweet people i wonder if the six-month
process of getting on the same page as a
nerd
and as the kind of the party personality
helped him uh maybe bridge the gap with
the football game i don't know i think
it was the way around the other way
around i think if you can get along
about football you can get along about
anything well that's the truth
you know what that's a good point i
fully expected during their debt free
scream to hear a little roll tide and
war eagle but we didn't hear it
well we'll go out here during the break
and see if we can get that recorded
right
well done dennis and christy
baby step millionaires
debt-free house and everything
hey folks you can do this stuff they
proved it lots of people prove it every
day it's all about you baby it's all
about you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your
careers
your relationships
your money and your life
it's a free call a triple eight eight
two five
five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five
two two five connie is with us in south
bend hi connie welcome to the ramsey
show
good afternoon
um me and my husband we're in our uh
mid-fifties we have no debt
we bring in
about 150 000 a year
we currently have about
766 000 in investments 165 000 and and a
profit sharing
he'll have something from teamsters
hopefully and then
we also have two reynolds homes um
both
their 150 000 value each and then our
current house is
about 250 000 in value way to go
thank you we have about 150 000 in cash
uh
we have really nobody to leave anything
to
um and what we're looking about doing is
um
i would like to we would like to buy
some land
um and we can get it at a fairly good
price
we're thinking about 50 000 we want to
put a um pole barn on it first before we
build a house the pole barn is going to
be about
150 000 and i'm guessing the house once
i get it priced out is going to be about
600 to 700 000.
so my whole quandary is
uh because you know most of this stuff
is in investments and properties and
things like that
what what's the best way to go about
doing everything without
um
the only thing i was thinking was like
if we sell one of the rental houses
this year and then sell one next year so
we can split the capital gains on them
and then
use that money to build the pole barn
but then for the house construction
rather than doing
anything with the investments would i
take a temporary mortgage out on my
current home in order to build the new
home
and then also should i stop putting
investments in roth if there's really no
point of keep
building so much money when we really
have nobody to leave anything to
the roth's not about leaving it to
someone or else about you having it
tax-free
so yeah you would keep putting money
into the roth that's the last question
first but um
[Applause]
so how much money in investments do you
have that's not in retirement accounts
um
only probably about
um
150
000
no i'm sorry that's grown that's about
300 000. okay let's use that first
okay unless you don't like the rentals
i i definitely want to get rid of the
rentals because the only reason we
bought them is their net next to the
house we current down and we wanted to
like control our neighbors
and
i'm too nice of a landlady i don't
hardly charge anything for them so
they're not really bringing anything in
well then dump them i'm with you okay
yep and they're going to bring 300 and
you've already got 300 that's 600 and it
sounds like you need um
uh 800.
at least yes that's that's
150 for a pole barn 50 to buy the land
that's 200 and 600 to build the house is
800.
yeah as long as prices don't keep going
up on this building well i mean that's
the the numbers you're giving me that
we're working with that's the numbers we
have does that include the 150 in cash
is that the 100 no that's that's
separate
okay oh so that's now you're only 150
off
yeah right yeah and so yeah i think you
can get i think you can get really deep
into this before you have to sell your
house
okay all right or even take a mortgage
out on it i'm not taking out a mortgage
on it
okay i don't want to either
i'm not gonna do it uh so what i would
do um and you said you're in your 50s
yeah i am 53 my husband is 55.
okay all right i mean if he gets to 59
and a half you can access some of the
retirement accounts here's the other
thing this is going to take a while and
so you're going to be able to with your
income cash flow the rest of it probably
so if you take the 150 cash the 300 and
non-retirement investments and the 300
from the rentals you're within 150 and
you can probably cash flow that 150 out
of your income between now and the time
you need it
and then move into the new house and
sell the old house
okay
no more we can use that money to invest
reinvest yeah no mortgage
excellent
you're probably not going to touch your
retirement at all
okay all right good yeah and you're
going to end up with a 2 million net
worth and a piece of property that's
worth
probably half of that now you buy then
your net worth will probably be two and
a half to three so
yeah
the way you're going so you're doing
really good well done well done it's
just a matter of laying these things out
and developing kind of a flow chart a
gantt chart we would call it a a
logistical game plan
oh nice i've never heard that it's a new
one i'm going to drop that in
conversation and look extra smart this
weekend like gantt again
just drop it in there leave it in there
like like you knew what it was then you
have to go look it up
[Laughter]
you know what my favorite part of the
call was is they bought the two rental
properties not because of investments
they just don't want to control their
neighbors people next to them i love
that i bought i have bought vacant lots
next to me for this reason i thought you
were connected i have made a lot of
money on vacant lots next to my house i
just saw one the other day for this is
what really did really well old house i
used to own yeah yeah that's that's a
good buffer lots are not a bad thing but
for buffer rentals i've not done but for
lots are not a bad thing
it's not a bad thing at all don's in
kansas city hey don welcome to the
ramsey show
hey love you guys and love the show
thanks for having me on sure how can we
help
well i got a question for you i'm 60
years old
i i had to restart
everything i was uh at age 50.
i'm getting close to being debt free i
still have a student loan forty two
thousand five hundred and some change
um
currently i'm i'm putting thirty percent
of my uh
my salary into a roth
and as soft as the market has become i
was wondering if i would be better off
cutting that back a little bit to say 15
of my salary and just attacking that
student loan uh so 1500 months at it and
knock it out in 30 months and just be
totally debt-free or
uh how much is in your retirement in
this stick
like i said i started over yeah
you've been
yeah it's uh
um a hundred thousand right now um but i
in the past ten years i've paid off uh
172 000 dollars
what's your income uh right now 55 in
that period of time between 40 and 55
okay so i i've been uh i've been eating
a lot of beans yeah yeah so
yeah you've been in recovery you've been
in recovery mode good for you you're a
strong guy
well here's what we teach don the
shortest path to wealth is to get clear
of debt first build an emergency fund
second and then start retirement so we
would teach you to temporarily stop all
investing
and dump everything you can squeeze out
of your entire life on that stupid
student loan and get rid of it finally
because it won't go away
and then once it's gone we take
everything in the budget make sure you
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses how much is in your
emergency fund now
i know about seventy eight hundred
dollars okay all right i'm gonna bring
that down to one thousand dollars as
baby step one is what we teach
and so that's going to give us 6 800 to
throw through the 42 000 and then we're
going to put everything entire budget
focus on the remaining 35 000 bucks and
you're going to knock that out very very
quickly
it's going to be about nine months
probably something like that you'll be
working extra you'll be beans and rice
rice and beans when the student loan's
gone then go back to the one thousand
dollar account raise it up to a fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then with not a
payment in the world and that nice
buffer you restart your retirement and
you hit it hard
and you start building build and build
and build in there and you're going to
be able to hit it even harder right now
you've got things going about six
different directions and they're not
giving you the power that they need to
give you hold on i'm going to send you a
copy of the book the total money
makeover to help you out this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today
as we talk about your career we talk
about your work we talk about your money
we talk about your life and your
relationships open phones a triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple a eight
two five five
two two five as we start off this
segment i'm gonna bring an old friend to
the line mitch album is with us mitch is
a seven times number one new york times
bestseller and uh most of us were first
introduced to mitch through
maury tuesday's with maury what a
wonderful book and he's written many
wonderful books since then and has been
a radio host as well and that's where we
met i think mitch originally was at a
talk radio convention wasn't it
i think that's right dave yeah how are
you doing good my brother how are you
i'm hanging in there thanks good good a
brand new book out the stranger in the
lifeboat another novel or a novel and um
this one's incredible uh i just got to
started thumbing through it and i think
i'll probably read it tonight i got a
feeling i'm just going to plow right
through it it looks like a pretty i i
got stuck i mean you open the middle of
the book and you start turning pages
that's not good right not good for
somebody like me i need to go back to
the beginning and get the whole story
but i i got a feeling of what's going on
what was the uh what brought this book
to your mind where did this creative
impulse come from
well i wanted to write a book about how
we ask for help in this world and
particularly when we ask for help from
god or the universe
and so i created this story about this
luxury yacht which has all these famous
rich celebrities on it and famous people
around the world and inexplicably out in
the middle of the ocean it blows up
and everyone's killed except 10 people
five of whom were the rich people and
five of whom are the staff
who serve them on the boat and they make
their way to a life raft and they're on
this life raft for three days
and nobody's coming for them and they're
running out of food and they see sharks
in the water and they're
crying out for help in every which way
and suddenly they see this body floating
in the water and they pull it into the
raft and it's this young guy
who's alive a non-descript average
looking skinny guy and they pepper him
with questions he doesn't answer and
finally one of the passengers says well
thank the lord we found you
and he says i am the lord.
and the book takes off from there and it
explores the whole idea of
you know when we cry out for help
if it comes but it's not the form we
expected because he's not he doesn't
look like a god he doesn't talk like it
he falls asleep he gets hungry he eats
and they don't believe he is who he says
he is
and he says i can save you but only if
everybody here believes i am who i say i
am and becomes a you know a parable
about
you know how do we accept help even if
it doesn't look like what we expected
yeah the whole element of faith having
faith to in order for the help to be
present
mitch
mitch ken coleman here i'm curious how
much of your own faith journey you two
of your books obviously with heaven in
the title uh i'm curious how much of
your faith journey and how you believe
we're supposed to respond to help and
and what our relationship with faith
looks like how much does it play out in
this narrative
well it was the impetus for it to be
honest ken personally i operate an
orphanage in haiti that i i'm at every
month for the last 12 years and i raise
along with my wife we have 54 kids there
and one of whom we adopted a few years
back when she developed a brain tumor
and
we tried to save her and for two years
we traveled around the world trying to
do so but we weren't successful in the
end and she died when she was seven
and i was extremely angry at the world
and at god and the universe and you know
i couldn't believe there's a benevolent
god who wouldn't be benevolent to a
seven-year-old
and it took me you know the four years
until i actually wrote this book
to start to look at it as like well
it's not
what we lost it's what we were given
and there's a moment in this book where
one of the characters asks
the god character you know okay well if
you're a god why do people have to die
you know why did my wife died why did
you take my wife
and the answer is well why do you always
ask when someone dies why did god take
them
maybe a better question would be why did
god give them to you what did we do to
deserve
or merit their attention their love all
the memories that they gave us i know
that you cry when your loved ones die
here on earth but i can assure you
they're not crying
and you know i wrote that as a character
for the book and there's a line in the
book but i kind of wrote it to myself
again because
that's sort of the attitude that i had
to sort of adopt i said wait a minute
why am i blaming god for taking her
instead of giving god credit for letting
us have her even for the few years we
had her which were the most glorious
years of our life
and we may be crying but she's not
crying where she is so yeah a lot of my
own kind of thoughts and things that
i've bumped along the way on my on my
life have found their ways into the
characters in this book
you have a uh have done
really well with a god-given talent that
you've worked so hard to develop to
weave a story around something that puts
a knot in my stomach and in my throat
i remember i remember crying like a 12
year old when i was reading two through
the morning oh yeah oh my goodness and
of course that book was not fiction
correct
right that's correct that was a true
story yeah and uh but i mean still the
storytelling ability that you've had and
a lot of people don't know that know you
from the book world uh that you're a
famous sports writer as well and uh so
you you definitely have an ability with
words and ability to weave a story but
um
the uh it isn't i'm a storyteller ken's
a storyteller we speak and communicate
for a living but you are unusually
talented at telling a a gripping heart
grabbing story congratulations on
another big hit uh mitch album the the
the uh the stranger in the lifeboat is
the brand new book i assume it's out now
oh yeah it came out in november and um
knock wood it's it's done very very well
it seems that uh
after covid i think a lot of people were
asking for help and and maybe not
getting it in the form that they you
know wanted and
all i can say to that is you know when
we don't think our prayers are being
answered
uh and we say oh you know god's not
paying attention to me think of how many
times you think something's bad and then
five ten years later you look back on it
and you say oh you know
at the time it was terrible but if that
hadn't happened then this wouldn't
happen then i wouldn't have met this
person i would have gotten married and
so i guess
in hindsight it was the best thing that
could have happened to me well if it's
the best thing that could have happened
to you 10 years from now it is the best
thing that can happen to you now it's
just you know we all want everything on
our plates right now you know like we're
ordering fast food and we can't always
understand the way god or the universe
works but usually if you take the long
view
most of the things you really want in
life you know are answered and in some
way form and i know they have been for
me and i hope that's what people can get
from stranger in the life though very
good stuff again the book the stranger
in the lifeboat the newest novel from
mitch album seven times number one
best-selling author and uh author of the
famous book tuesdays with maury which if
you have not read you need to get that
on the list as well just pick up both of
them while you're at it it'll give you
something to do so uh mitch good to talk
to you my friend congratulations on all
your success
thank you dave good to hear your voice
again thank you ken you guys have a
great day come visit when you're in
nashville brother all right mitch album
the stranger in the lifeboat be sure and
check it out this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay married people imagine never having
another money argument whoa
what'd that feel like
how much better would your marriage be
what about your whole family when you
get on the same page with money you'll
have more peace in your finances and
your marriage here's the best part
you can do it by joining a financial
peace university class you'll learn how
to make a budget together sounds like
valentine's and follow our proven money
plan so you can stop fighting about
money start chasing your goals as a team
millions
of couples have gone through this class
and they say it's one of the best things
they ever did for their marriage
and it can be for you too
so decide today that you're ready to get
on the same page with your spouse about
money join a financial peace university
class you can get started with a free
trial
visit ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu
this
is the ramsey show ken coleman is my
co-host today he is the host of the ken
coleman show where he talks about career
talks about work and talks about your
work life his number one bestselling
book paycheck to purpose is out there
zoom zooming we had it come out last
fall it's done extremely well he's here
to answer your questions about life and
money and so am i so you jump in and
we'll talk the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
joanna is with us in st louis hi joanna
how are you
hi i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um i feel like the question needs a
little backstory um i'm super new to all
this i
started
listening to the podcast a couple weeks
ago and read the book that had been
living around collecting dust
my my husband's job cut over time
suddenly
which is about twenty thousand dollars a
year for us
and we just went into absolute panic
mode
so i read the book
in our snow days we had three days where
we got snowed in and i read the entire
book cover to cover and i got really
excited and
hopeful and serious about it and
he is um
not so much on the same page he's super
defeated at his job he hates his job
he's miserable he feels like there's
some coercion to do some medical
procedures that he's not interested in
and just a lot of bullying in general
and what he really wants to do is be a
law enforcement officer which is a total
career shift and would require
you know going to a special school and
not working while he does that and
i'm trying to translate all this
information to him
and
he just hears me and says i mean that's
stupid
credit is necessary that is necessary
you know we need to buy a house sooner
even later he wants to leave the city
and buy a house in springfield
there's all these pieces and
i think his anxiety is so high about his
job situation that he just can't hear me
and
i wonder if he had any advice about
kind of the best way to
get through to him because i think this
could really
shift everything for us sorry feeling a
little emotional that's okay sure
joanna let me ask you very quickly what
does he do now what is his job so he
works in loan operations um finance
so
yeah he's kind of the back end of an
agricultural
loan company a huge one and what's his
what's his salary or what's his earning
now that he's lost that 20 000 in
overtime he's he's been about 40 000 and
with my three jobs i'm i'm coming in
right under 40 as well okay
um so we were doing a little better but
we you know we have all the stupid
debt we have like 15 000
credit cards we have 8 000 left on our
car we have some phone payments and
student loans
um i didn't actually realize how bad it
was until i totaled it all this week
which was alarming
um but
he's a little bit more spendy than i am
i would say we both swipe the credit and
debit card too often but
this is just so overwhelming for him and
i don't think he finds you to be a
credible source because i tend to get
excited about things
and go all in and then maybe not finish
them which is my own weakness that i'm
working on
[Music]
okay
um
well there's a lot going on here at one
time there is not a simple
it's not as simple the light is switches
off flip the switch on it's uh
a whole lot of things happening um
sounds also like there's babies in the
background yeah i'm a nanny so we're on
a walk this is the only time okay
that's okay i'm just making sure i
didn't i didn't know what it was one of
her three jobs okay
i have a 10 year old
so that's a piece of the puzzle as well
she has some special needs so
definitely a lot going on okay um
yeah i think when uh
you're home and he's home and the baby's
in bed we turn off the television
and um i i think you just tell him
not what you guys are doing wrong and
not how excited you are about what you
read in the total money makeover but how
scared you are
okay i'm scared
and i'm scared that if we keep spending
and we keep using credit like we've been
doing it's never worked
it's gotten us in this mess we've never
been able to move out of the mess
everything gets bad as soon as it gets
tight
and i don't see you being able to go and
live your
new career as long as we're financially
strapped and so i want you to be able to
do that and i don't want to be afraid
anymore and the only way i can see to do
those two things
me to not be afraid
and um
you to not be overwhelmed with and
anxious and you to be able to move to a
different career is for us to get a
detailed game plan a financial game plan
to get there
because if we didn't if we didn't have
any debt
and we had some money in savings we
could talk a lot more
about you moving into a different career
but right now we can't even breathe and
you can't breathe and i can't breathe
and i'm scared
instead of you
uh accusing him of being the spender or
accusing him of
not getting it or you've got to get on
the same page or you have to read this
book or
instead of those things and i think you
draw him
into this conversation because
everything i heard in the whole
conversation this man loves his wife
he absolutely does yeah
and
if he's not being attacked by his wife
instead she's saying help me
this is a guy who will come to her
rescue
yeah i think i tend to be the like
positive one in all circumstances so he
sees me a little bit delusional
when things are overwhelming um i guess
i'm always worried about coming to him
and saying that i'm scared or feeling
hopeless
it's going to just pile on top of him
well it's i i think he can handle it
yeah also understand joanna he's very
discouraged right now and you mentioned
that but he's very discouraged and to
the extent that you can lift him by
saying he has no control over his
company cutting overtime and i and i
would throw a practical encouragement in
here
if i were talking to your husband right
now
the path to him being a law enforcement
officer besides paying off the debt and
getting financially stable
is the hottest job economy we've seen in
the history of this country and because
of his loan finance experience and skill
set
he needs to be looking at as a bridge to
pay off the debt
as getting a better job in the finance
sector that's the next step more income
he's going to feel better about himself
and you're bringing in more income and
you get out of that place because that
place is killing him yeah so i think you
know it really is yeah and i think you
just start talking about listen if you
keep doing what you've been doing
you're going to keep getting what you've
been getting
it's true
something's got to change
and so the only thing i know to do is
continue to try to talk about it in this
setting and if you can't get some kind
of movement and some kind of agreement
if he's going to sit in a corner
then you've got to seek some help you
guys got to seek some marriage
counseling sit down with your pastor and
start trying to get somebody to speak
life over the two of you and get this
thing moving because it's all swirling
so fast around you it's all spun up and
out of control i can hear it in your
voice
and
the good news is i know when you guys
get on a game plan uh that you can do
this so hold on we're going to send you
a copy of ken coleman's book for your
husband from paycheck to purpose
and we're going to put you guys into
financial peace university and kelly's
going to sign you up for that in ramsey
plus i'll give you everything you need
to turn this around but then you guys
got to go do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget
don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
author of the number one bestseller from
paycheck to purpose
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage patrick and chelsea are
with us hey guys how are you fantastic
hey dave hey ken welcome where do you
guys live just north of austin texas oh
fun well welcome to nashville good to
have you and all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
265 000.
how long did that take just under six
years good for you and your range of
income during that time around 85 to
around 175 and this year would be north
of 200. wow nice job what do you all do
for a living
so i'm in education sales for a data and
analytics company and chelsea works
harder than i do she stays at home with
these three kids oh okay
all right so the data sales business is
going better and better and better it's
a good time for that absolutely good for
you man so i'm going to guess and say
with that amount of money in that number
of years that that's the house
yes it is you paid off
talking to weird people
how old are you two
i am 39 and i'm 44. and you have to pay
for a house we got to pay four houses
you're weird feels good i love you
you're awesome man so very cool good for
you
good for you so what starts you guys on
a paid off house journey
seven or six years ago boy i tell you
what it starts a long time ago so i
remember sitting in the church around
2001 watching a video a financial piece
video maybe a live event
and we were dating at the time and i
started talking to her so chelsea we if
we're going to get married we need to
think about this and so we started
talking about this she said wait she's
married she said what
about all this
and so fast forward we got married we
paid off her student loan we bought this
house about six little over six years
ago with a goal of paying it off in 15
years 15-year fixed-rate mortgage uh we
said maybe we could do it in 10 and uh
we had some good things happen we had
some challenges along the way and uh
what do you know almost you know six
years later and here we are wow you guys
fit the uh template exactly i mean the
typical person going through total money
makeover financial piece they get their
home paid off in about seven years it's
not unusual at all well done
what's this house worth
boy it's gone high now it's about 6 15.
oh
and you've been investing all this time
we have been so you're every day your
baby steps millionaires so i don't want
them to hear that
yes yes we are yes we are it's a secret
yeah there's no way you're not that's
awesome way to go
well done how much have you gotten in
investments we've got around 450 right
now in investments all right so you're
bumping a million two million three then
well done thank you i love it
that's what happens when you're sitting
in church yes
it's one of the benefits
i like it so i love to hear the story
and everybody just heard dave say this
is on track you guys are right on track
a little bit ahead of the average there
but it's interesting that you set out
for the 15 year
and then you're like i think we can do
it 10. and then i think we can do it
sooner than that you end up doing it you
know really in six years so what happens
emotionally i'd love for the audience to
hear from you all what happens is you
begin to see that momentum and you
realize we can get there faster
i think something that was cool for me
was our kids got old enough to
realize what was happening and
they really pushed us like they
were getting involved they were wanting
to
you know be a part of it and um for me
it was not just okay we're gonna do this
in 15 years we're gonna just do you know
it was it was
you know growing grind it out my 12 year
old knows knows what a mortgage is and
and that i didn't know what a mortgage
was i don't even know if i knew what one
it was in college so
it's crazy that she's talking about our
mortgage and you know um
and not having one anymore and it's
that so we were going to say something
sorry no i was going to say you know
in 2015 in december i lost my job
and it was a scary time and thankfully
we had a fully funded emergency fund in
place
and thankfully i have this incredible
wife beside me that has that has
encouraged me and supported me they have
a married way up she's an incredible
woman i'm so blessed to be here standing
beside her today
but she supported me and we clawed out
of that situation and you know six years
later we saw the hope we saw we could do
it we started to believe and as we got
closer these kids started getting
involved they started getting excited to
see the look on their faces and to
realize we have an opportunity to change
their family tree they've been a part of
the giving as we've gone through this
and it's exciting it's exciting to see
where we've come from and where we can
go wow
and i think what happens too and you
tell me if i'm wrong because sometimes
people say oh well the math you use just
doesn't work and i always tell people
because the math we use always works
because it's never the way we map when
you map it out because when you mapped
out paying that house off in 10 years or
11 years you did that at your income at
that time you didn't anticipate
in that math that your income was going
to go
you know from 85 to 185 hello
you know and so yeah you look at that
you go we ought to be able to put a
bigger yeah and a little more yeah and a
little more yeah and and all of a sudden
you're going we're going to knock this
out and you start to see the math and
and there's there's act it's a weird
thing but there's actually hope and math
yes yes that's right you know what's
interesting too is i know people hear
this the kids got involved because you
were letting them see it hear it and
then they begin to get involved and that
give you some extra juice is what i'm
hearing
it really did
they've been asking for three years when
are we going to pay off the house we're
going to be at the house because we're
going to nashville we've been able
that's come up many times i can tell you
they've wanted to come here for a long
long time so this is a highlight for us
and a highlight for them um but they've
been excited they've been you know
throughout this with with give save and
spend they've been a part of it they've
sat down they've seen us budget um and
they've wanted to
wanted to be here and so it's really
been fun to see their spirit to see them
change and and see the things that we
can do we were able to give some money
at christmas and they would be able to
be a part of that and so it's really fun
to see the excitement in their eyes does
change your family tree not just the
math parts not just the fact that we
have some wealth but the kids are
changed they're different than like she
said you know you didn't know what a
mortgage was in college but now i got a
12 year old knows we don't have one
that's
pretty cool that's so that's a big
that's a change in your family tree
that's what that means
that's how you do it and uh this is how
rich people handle their money is they
teach their kids about money and they
teach them about the importance of
wealth and they teach them about the
responsibility around it and that's what
this whole family's doing they're
incredible well you guys are rock stars
yeah this is absolutely powerful thank
you proud of you thank you dave i'll say
that we i want to give glory to god
because we never thought this was
possible we didn't know how we were
going to do it we had a goal and god's
been faithful he has blessed us beyond
all we could imagine and uh we are just
so thankful for you and your team and
the opportunity to be here today we're
thankful for you man you guys are while
we're here so powerful blessed blessed
blessed this is so fun well we've got a
copy of uh your autobiography baby steps
millionaires and i'll give you a copy of
that and uh you can share that with
friends and family that don't think it
can be done because lots of people
actually doing this lots and lots and
lots of them are doing this and uh now a
number one best seller so also a copy
total money makeover for you to give
away and stir someone up and get them
started on the whole process because you
can't keep from talking about it once
you have a little bit of success in this
not to brag but to brag on what god has
done and to brag on uh his principles
work and to brag on this cause and
effect thing that when you plant corn
you grow corn yeah you guys are amazing
well done very very well done all right
let's bring the kiddos in what are their
names and ages so mckenna is 12. that's
mckenna miranda is 10.
and maybe
one yeah
yeah we're ready
all right patrick and chelsea and the
team from austin texas 265 000 paid off
in six years making 85 to 175 and baby
steps millionaires count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Music]
since that 12 year old was six
they've been talking about this
[Applause]
legacy boom
that's how you do it right there man
that's exactly how you do it and that's
why we come down here every day man
powerful stuff
the point for you watching and you
listening is
you too
can do this
that wasn't an easy trip they've been on
it was just a trip worth taking this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show
we talk about careers and work as my
co-host today
taking your calls about your work your
career your money your relationships
it's all right here on the ramsey show
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five michael is
with us in morristown new jersey hey
michael what's up
hi david ken how are you guys great man
how can i help
so
student loan question again no surprise
there um i'm 26 years old
i believe that my i have a student loan
from my first year at college before i
had transferred and
private school
expensive and
so uh this student loan was taken out
under my mother's name it's not
no attachment to me
nothing on my credit score or anything
for that
and um you know after seeing how
expensive this private school was i had
transferred out and everything and then
the rest of my college was a cash flowed
so
uh yeah it's under her name and
after all that
i see that it is
about fifty thousand dollars in student
loans and what they had
my mother and my father told me was they
had
half of that uh in cash but then we
still have this loan and
if that's true that's
great but i don't want them to be
dealing with this loan if it's mine
for my school i just wanted to know your
opinion on that
okay sounds like it's a parent plus loan
i think it might be but that's the only
way you can take out a student loan for
your kid
okay otherwise otherwise it would be in
your name what do you make michael
i know 75 000. okay good what do you do
for a living
i am a financial analyst good what debt
do you have other than this issue
um other than this nothing actually i am
um
we're trying to also cash flow a wedding
and buy a house but right now where my
fiance and i are actually living with my
parents
oh okay
okay cool when do you get married
next july
a year from july
yes 2023 okay all right um
[Music]
all right so it doesn't sound like you
can mathematically address this issue
today anyway
right so
i think i might be able to because i do
have
about 30 000 saved up for
uh
just in my bank account right now and
then also have
about 20 000 and 401k
well you can't really access the 401k as
you know
um right unless i get hit with a huge
tax break up like that well now you just
quit your job you can't cash out a 401k
while you still work there
um well these are from prior from prior
to
higher companies that i was with okay
yeah you would get hammered with taxes
and i would not suggest that any
circumstances so but you told me you're
trying to cash flow a wedding
yes that as well
and where's that money coming from
also coming from working between my
fiancee and i yes
and what does she make
she makes about 60.
okay
all right um
well your parents are not bothering you
about it you're just worried that you
might
accidentally be shirking your
responsibility
even though it's never really been
stated one way or the other in your
family the
the issue of responsibility between you
and your mom and dad is not real clear
legally it's not yours but morally they
didn't expect they haven't said they
expected you to and you haven't really
talked about it
right so actually right before uh covet
and these
interests were you know deferred i was
making some payments on it and
you know the with what that was and what
the interest was wasn't much to it and
then i haven't made a payment to that
one since um or of that since
so what does the discussion with your
parents sound like you randomly paying
payments on something they think they
owe
not even if they think they owe it is
for me and they had mentioned that they
were also helpful with that but they
haven't helped with that yet and
again morally i'd love to take care of
that because it was for my school i
believe so
um yeah that's okay now that you're
asking if you should take care of it
you've already made the decision
i made a decision yeah of course morally
i'd love to take care of it okay
well then you just put it in your lineup
you've got a wedding
and you've got a student loan and you've
got a house purchase
i'll help you with this the house
purchase is down the line past the other
two the wedding's probably in front and
then we'll address the student loan
okay sounds like you need to cash flow
the wedding get the budget together and
put that money in the wedding account
boom boom ken what are you seeing am i
missing something yeah i agree i think
you've got this thirty thousand dollars
set aside so how much of that are you
planning to use for the wedding or do
you think you can cash flow
the your part of the wedding cost uh
from your paycheck or is mom and dad
gonna put up 25k that they've still got
set aside half of it that was mentioned
earlier in the conversation you put up
25k and call it a day you're done yeah
that's what i'm hoping
we can end up doing as long as we both
agree on that now but um
again like i was saying i
morally i would just feel like this was
for my school i should take it well it's
okay for mom and dad to pay for part of
your school
right that's not immoral
i paid for my kids school 100 of it
didn't pay for any of it
i saved up they had a college fund they
went to college
and if your mom and dad had 25 000 to
put towards your college
and in this situation the way that
manifests itself is it goes towards this
loan
and then you pick up the rest of your
college you cash flowed it and you've
knocked this the other 25 000 of this
out you have done nothing morally or
ethically wrong now does that mean your
mom and dad can't eat next week if they
do that
no no it definitely does not mean that
okay all right so i'm gonna sit down and
have a real clear conversation with them
and your fiance sitting at the table
and all four of you at dinner table and
just say hey i want to do what's right
here i feel like i owe this at one time
you said you want to put up 25 if you
want to do that towards my education and
i put up 25 we can call this a day the
stupid loan is gone and then we'll sit
down and budget for the next year and a
half and be ready for this wedding
yep okay i think that's a great idea and
then once you're married we're worried
about a house but i ain't worried about
a house right now at all you got plenty
of time this is a conversation with mom
and dad what are they willing to do and
if they're not and if they're kicking
the can down the road then he's got to
take you know the lead on it well and
your fiance doesn't need to hold this
against them for the next 30 years
because it was unclear so it's good for
her to sit at the table too i agree i
like lots of lots of just play all the
cards face up on the table lots of
clarity
there's a lot of fuzziness around the
edges right of what you all think about
this and it's kind of unsaid things and
the you know the danger of that dave is
is when everybody is got their own
thought on clarity but no one is
uniformly clear we're not all clear
together we start to fill in that gap
with our own thoughts but feelings get
in there it's like whoa whoa whoa let's
make sure everybody knows what we're
thinking and then that clarity provides
beautiful boundaries and a plan clarity
is usually
feels
awkward
feels stressful
feels almost like conflict that's right
but it actually avoids
more relational problems
than it creates and so lots of real
clear calm kind
noble conversation
listen to what the other side's saying
and this is what and then come to a
conclusion
that this is the plan
and then this is what we're gonna do and
then there's no then there's no yeah you
don't have to worry about it again it's
over right it's just a matter of
execution then yes and so we come into
alignment which level set we whatever
whatever all these phrases we throw
around out here is but i mean this thing
on clarity it's uh
the unsaid is just devastating in this
type of relationship and folks this is
the reason you don't do these loans by
the way
you get you get you get everybody all
twisted up like a freaking pretzel yeah
i mean it just messes with relationships
so true yeah loan you wanna you wanna
lose a friendship loan your friend money
you know the old joke is if you don't
want your brother-in-law to speak to you
if you loan your brother-in-law a
hundred dollars and he never speaks to
you again was it worth it you know
that's the old joke right i love my
brother-in-law's but um everywhere
across america people are going well i
think i'm gonna make a small loan to my
brother-in-law i think i gotta think
i've got a plan for valentine's here
no don't do that please no that's not
but i mean the point is it puts stress
on everything as it does and there's all
this fuzz in the air
and uh that's what we're hearing here
you can feel it and feel it so
lots of clarity crisp
clear
precise
and then execute
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsyshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality best-selling author
of the book paycheck to purpose is my
co-host as we talk about your work we
talk about your relationships your jobs
your money your life all right here in
front of you open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five
two two five new jobs report out uh
where the jobs are all in one chart
very interesting explosion
in january jobs
in
guess what
leisure and hospitality yeah so if you
look at the top three categories first
of all
four to fifty thousand jobs nobody
predicted that one right because we were
still hearing things of omicron
spreading and so you know what fifty 000
new jobs taken
new jobs were taken yes in the month of
january yeah a big spike and so if we
look at where those are broken down
leisure and hospitality 151 000 of those
so clearly what's happening is we've got
restaurants are
reopening in some states across the
country some are staffing back up with
due to restrictions coming down i mean
that's just the reality we're seeing in
a lot of states depending on we're not
getting into politics but that is how
this is divided and so as states are
opening up so is the leisure and
hospitality industry and so they're
staffing up obviously professional and
business services that's just a fancy
way of saying small businesses
corporations businesses are hiring that
was the second highest amount of jobs 86
000 and then this is interesting the
third highest was retail 61 000. so
we're seeing
slowly the falling across the country as
it relates to
restrictions and kind of the traditional
economy and so we're seeing retail uh
which has been hit very hard during the
pandemic seeing those jobs being added
it's very interesting and then final
piece transportation and warehousing
this is good for manufacturing uh
specifically dave we've we've seen a big
supply chain problem
uh maybe you've seen it in your grocery
stores depending on where you're
listening and viewing from
but truckers there's a need uh as of
november of 2021
they needed 80 000 truckers to fully
staff up on the supply chain 7 500
truckers were added in the month of
january so it's kind of a snapshot of
not just what's happening but where the
opportunities are
for people if well let's just be real
you need a bigger shuffle you know uh
you need to add that second or third job
this is what people are hiring
from an economics standpoint um
in just the movement and the disruption
of labor
the pandemic was
dramatically unfair
to
those who could least afford it
servers
hotel maids
hourly wager and there's people working
people working retail
none of these are
super high paid gigs
by and large
uh not none of them but most of them
aren't
and uh they were
inordinately the hardest hit
because those were the people that got
completely shut down
and now that medical freedom is coming
back
and people are free
to in some states has been for quite a
while and some it's just now a brand new
thing
to reopen and travel and stay in a hotel
and go to a restaurant now we've got
states that that's still virtually
impossible to do but the the
the thing i was hearing at first is is
that they couldn't get them to come back
to work that's true so uh i'm wondering
if this surge
in leisure and hospitality as an example
is the fact that the freaking
unemployment just ran out yeah well they
had to go back to work yeah well we've
got to very magically they went back to
work when there's no more unemployment
that's right
that's part of it but we're also seeing
that the pandemic itself spun off a
whole bunch of jobs that didn't exist
pre pandemic so when you're watching the
news folks and you hear this well we've
got this employment gap we've got more
jobs available it's about 10.3 million
versus people are unemployed we're now
getting into low h we're folks we're
steamrolling towards a three percent
dave you're going to see unemployment
rate in the threes very soon which is by
far below
real employment it's oh yeah we're in a
deficit yeah so what's going on couple
things more jobs have been created that
didn't exist pre-pandemic a lot of
health services job you have a lot of
support staff that are being hired to
support doctors and nurses that's one
example of where
hospitals have staff staffed up now the
other thing that we've seen dave is that
more people are starting businesses in
the pandemic if they were laid off or
furloughed or maybe they stayed with it
but they got some stimulus money and
they wanted to start that side hustle
as you know and we teach this
entrepreneurship all the time in entre
leadership the barrier for entry is
lower than it has ever been in the
united states to start a business so
we're seeing on the rolls now more
companies have so they're not our
startup business didn't go back to the
show didn't go back they also now need
to hire people they do even more so you
think about the person who is making an
hourly wage as a waitress or maybe
working in a night shift at a hotel okay
so you're looking at i'm just ball
parking this but this is somewhere
between a 10 to maybe 12 an hour job
so they can now repent pre-pandemic so
now it's 22 it has jumped however they
went out and said hey i can replace that
and i don't have to work the crazy hours
you know whatever you've been put up
with crazy people at your local chain
restaurant these are the restaurants by
the way that have struggled the most
your faster food services for instance
stacy and i we went to a lovely dinner
locally with uh my in-laws and my
brothers just told this weekend we went
to a five-star restaurant let me tell
you something they haven't struggled at
all uh other than the initial shutdown
the servers in there are making bank
because it's a great experience and the
food's correct and the services they're
the servers the servers are making great
money because people want to go to a
high-end experience and have great food
if you look at the chain restaurants you
just looked at human behavior that's
where we saw less traffic and things
kind of contract so all that said
we've seen a great entrepreneurship
explosion we're seeing the tip of it
over the next six months i think you're
going to see a record amount of business
starts in fact we already know from the
bureau of labor statistics applications
to start businesses the highest rate has
ever been there's so the supreme court
mandate comes out and the supreme court
comes aside and sets the biden mandate
aside for vaccines so companies like
ours at ramsey
if you want to get a vaccine you can but
we're not going to interfere in your
medical freedom you get to decide we
don't make you do anything
with your medical freedom one way or the
other that's right and uh so companies
like ours are hiring like crazy and
people are leaving these companies that
are clamping down on their med taking
their medical freedoms and coming to
companies like ours so we're still
seeing that great resignation move some
of it is associated with the medical
freedom issue some of it is associated
with just this waking up and i hate my
job and life's too short and the
pandemic reminded me someday i'm going
to die that's right and one other thing
that we've seen happen
companies because you saw the hourly
wage go up with target walmart amazon
leading the way here's what's happening
people are leaving their jobs record
pace 20 million people have left their
jobs over the last five months it's
going to continue why because there's a
great kind of arms race with companies
they're enticing people with signing
bonuses and bigger salaries and that's
going to catch up to people however if
you need a bigger shovel and you're in
the ramsey tribe go get it yeah go get
it now yeah it's going to last forever
because it's not house prices aren't
going to be this and job prices aren't
going to be this quite hot forever
supply demand curves always shift one
way or the other they never stay exactly
where they are and that includes the
supply of labor that's correct this is
the ramsey shaft
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
so
[Music]
[Music]
open phones this hour ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host thanks for
joining us tax season is upon us i know
try to contain your excitement
sorry dave i have the doggie bag here
for just a moment oh
my stomach no one likes your taxes uh
especially when you realize what the big
software companies are up to every year
these companies lure you in by saying
you can file your taxes for free then
when you're knee deep in the filing
process they sucker punch you with up
charges
offers to get into debt and credit card
pitches
somehow i think you got sold there's a
better way to do it it's called ramsey
smart tax this is our online tax filing
software with ramsey smart tax you get
all the deductions all the forms and
every tax break you deserve and the best
part is the price ours is already much
lower than the leading competitor and
there won't be hidden fees
plus this year you'll have a promo code
that'll make it truly free to file your
federal taxes go to ramsey solutions dot
com slash tax to get your promo code and
file without surprises ramsey solutions
dot com slash
smart tax i said it wrong slash smart
tax
and uh oh by the way if you're a ramsey
plus member and thousands millions of
you are uh you you can use the ramsey
smart text to file for free as well so
it's out there we're just trying to help
you
and if you want to hear about uh
the uh people that begin with the t
and it sounds like turbo
um do you want to hear about them just
listen to george camel on the fine print
uh broadcast where he exposes the scams
that are out there and you'll have a
whole new
view
on the innocuous little turbo
all right uh erica is with us in
cincinnati hi erica welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
yeah so i was given a trust fund when i
was 13. um i'm now 26 and i have about
300 000 internet trust funds for
emergencies and other necessities
i have 250 000 in a savings account and
then currently my husband and i have 142
000
mortgage with a 2.5 interest rate and a
combined income of about 80 000
we plan on going to the mission field in
the next three to five years if the lord
wills and so i'm wondering if i should
pay off the house now
if we have the money in the savings
accounts to do so and then rent it out
as a mission house while we're away or
continue paying our mortgage and just
sell the house when we leave
i'm just also wondering what to do with
the money moving forward i opened a roth
ira last year and we have about forty
thousand dollars in crypto investment
um we have no kids but we hope to
someday i just don't wanna waste this
money i wanna be a good uh steward of
the resources god has given me but it
just seems irresponsible for me to pay
interest very good for you yeah i would
pay off the house for sure
and then you can decide when you go on
the mission field if you want to keep it
as a rental or you want to sell it and
use that money to invest and live off of
the investment either way you could live
off the rental investment or you could
live off the same amount of money from
the sold house into a mutual fund
investment right
yeah yeah either way yeah i work for uh
i work for a property management company
and they say absolutely not to
potentially paying off my house they
think it's nuts to consider
well yeah i know but they're not as
wealthy as you are
they're not the person you work for
doesn't have the same net worth you do
you're wealthier than they are
and so you know i don't really care
when broke people don't like your
financial plan that's usually a good
sign why is there something that you
would do specifically with it i'm sorry
i i lost you you dropped the phone or
something
am i doing everything good so far
you dropped the phone or something i
lost you where'd you go
okay yeah that's what i would do i would
pay off the house it's that simple paul
is with us paul is in springfield
massachusetts hi paul welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave hi ken
hey what's up
quick question for you i'm on my
church's finance committee and we're
going to be having a capital campaign
fundraiser coming up
for a new social center
and
in massachusetts the marijuana industry
is now legal and so i i've been thinking
about
what what is your
thoughts on
receiving donations or soliciting
donations from
someone who you know makes a living from
that industry
and is it something that we should
consider or not consider i know you
always say money is neither moral or
immoral and uh even though i'm against
it should i not care about it or
should i care about
it well who are you are you talking
about just walking out in the community
and knocking on doors or these people in
your church
there are people are in the church
they're in the church okay so you have a
guy that sells pot legally that goes to
your church
right does he tithe or give
i do not know that
[Music]
okay what is your
uh
spiritual your church's spiritual stand
on this in the community
um i think we're against it
um
you know but then i sort of say well if
it was a liquor store
which you know not a big drinker at all
but uh you know i don't think we have
any problem with that so then i'm like
is it just am i trying to be
overthinking it or not overthinking it
well i i uh both are certainly legal in
your state
okay the question is how you all
perceive it
as a as a church okay from a spiritual
viewpoint um if you are if your pastor
stands up in the pulpit and preaches
against drinking under any circumstances
then even though a liquor store is legal
you shouldn't take money from them that
would be hypocritical
agreed right
and if he stands up in the pulpit and
says even though marijuana is now legal
we don't think it's good we think that
you know smoking pot getting high as a
sin i don't think you ought to do that
then you know taking
uh
money from the local weed store is
hypocritical
right
yeah that's what i mean now if you're
but if your pastor is ambivalent about
it and your pastor and the spiritual
leaders the uh the deacons the elders
however your church is governed and
structured from a spiritual standpoint
if they're ambivalent about it and they
they they put you know pot in the same
category as liquor
then
you know and and you're not you know you
don't have an issue from a spiritual
standpoint if we wouldn't call it sin
okay then then
you know uh uh for instance the church
that i go to
uh alcohol is not something that is
preached against
obviously in moderation but having a
glass of wine or a glass of bourbon or
something like that our pastor does not
scream and yell and get read in the face
about it okay and so that church
receiving tithes from the local liquor
store would not be a problem uh
you know at the church that i attend as
an example okay but if you went to a
church that had that stance there to
receive the money is hypocritical
so i think you need to establish where
you all stand on this issue and then
that will tell you
spiritually where you stand and that
will tell you whether to take the money
or not
make sense
yes it does and as a member of the
finance committee you've got to talk to
church leadership about this get their
position on it as dave's laid it out
i'll give you another example okay i'll
give you another example most
evangelical churches would be strongly
pro-life anti-abortion
and to take tithe money
or capital campaign money from an
abortion doctor that attends that church
would be uh would be hypocritical as
crud
right
is it you know it's the money is not
dirty
but the person that you're you're
allowing them to attend the church
because you hope you can change them you
hope you can lead them to a better way
of life
a better way of living a better a better
set of activities if you believe that
what they're doing is wrong okay and so
you've gotta but you know and i'm
assuming
let's just make a you know let's just
make an example here further at your
church if your church says hey
we don't believe smoking pot is okay
from a spiritual standpoint we don't
believe that if they take that stand
then they not only should not accept
this money but they also should begin to
walk with their arm around this weed
store owner and lead him into your way
of thinking or
make him uncomfortable enough that he
finds a church where it's okay to own a
wheat store
you know and that because it needs to be
consistent in a spiritual walk and we
need to be clear about what's
what is sin what isn't in your in the
way you all take a stand on staff but
the money itself is not dirty
it's how we're treating the people
kindly and kindly disagree with them
if we need to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your work
your life your money
your relationships on the debt-free
stage in the lobby of ramsey solutions
nick and danny are with us hey guys how
are you hey we're awesome we're good
welcome welcome where do you guys live
when you would oklahoma all right norman
area uh yeah three miles away from joe
exotic oh oh well not really he didn't
live there anymore but yeah
i almost said he was a new domain he
lives in yeah yeah
but you got to be famous for something
yeah exactly i got a friend i got a
friend that's from ada and the uh
the innocent man project though murder
series he's like aydah's now famous for
that right yeah oh man amazing well yeah
welcome guys good to have you how much
debt have you paid off 75 000 all right
how long did this take
three and a half years all right and
your range of income during that time
it was it was uh 39 000 started out and
then now it's four times that so like
150
yeah i mean it's
it's yeah it's it's gone up i'm just
yeah
i feel like there's a mystery that dave
and i aren't aware of he doesn't want to
say because somebody's listening
well we're self-employed too so then
there's like you know it kind of is a
little bit what do you do for a living
what's your business i'm a uh i'm my
dave ramsey smart buster
well proud i'm glad your income went up
then
those those ramsey leads are working out
for you yes they are good i'm glad
that's very good cool okay so what kind
of debt was your 75 000
our house all right look at the weird
people
good good excellent and uh that's
everything how old are you two
thirty-three thirty-three thirty-three
years old paid four house what's his
house worth 350 probably wow
so danny do you work do you work outside
the home uh yes i clean toilets for a
living okay cool clean houses good for
you good for you good for you so you
guys are doing really well
congratulations
and you have a 350 000 paid for home 33
years old not a debt in the world tell
us the story how did this happen
well uh we were going to school in
weatherford and uh nick had your radio
station on an am station i was like why
are you always listening to am stations
and i was
like exactly i was like you're so weird
and then i just got hooked on you and
sean hannity and i was like wow these
guys are awesome
and that would have been almost 10 years
ago we went through fpu
like eight years ago did the debt
snowball
paid off all our consumer debt and then
became a financial advisor and
eventually
you know bought a house paid it off so
it's kind of been in
you know stages yeah but but you are 33
years old with a paid for house
nice stages
yeah nice job well done well done so now
you can sit down
with uh someone twice your age and look
them in the eye and go well my house is
paid for
that's true
because i tell people not to take
financial advice from rogue people but
he ain't broke people
he is this is good that's great this is
very good i like it good good good okay
so what do you tell people the key
you've been through the stages you've
done it in the waves the way you're
supposed to baby steps four five six are
supposed to take a little bit longer
you're supposed to be living life while
you did it and it's exactly what you did
you paid off all the consumer debt
coming out of financial peace university
what's the key
to getting out of debt i would say put
first things first begin with the end in
mind
um
work hard we cut ten thousand dollars
worth of firewood to pay for our wedding
like well i've built more fence than any
woman should ever build
yeah we've just we've always had two
jobs we just have always just hustled so
it's hard work but now it shifted
basically but it took years and years to
get it like that but now it's like we
could let off the throttle
and come here you know and do stuff like
this so i i kind of think danny can work
rings around all of us i mean
from building fence and shopping
firewood to cleaning toilets i'm just
saying and so that's what i i can i just
tell you you're just impressive i love
your joy and i want to tell you
something i love how when dave asked you
what you do mind you folks she's debt
free no house payment and you said with
a giant smile i clean toilets for a
living
that that's awesome
there is honor and all work and i got to
tell you there's something special about
you and the hard work why do you say
that with that much joy
i love what i do i read your book from
paycheck to purpose and i was like man i
love my job i wish i would have done it
when i got out of high school like
just making moms happy like when they
come home to a clean house clean sheets
like i don't know it just brings joy to
my heart
you said cleaning toilets but that's
what you do you know what you're you're
in the joy business you give moms joy
and a little bit of respite from all of
the for one day for one day one day yeah
we get all the uh all the uh you know
the cheez-its out of the couch for
heaven's sakes
yeah that's a big deal yeah i applaud
you thank you you guys have a wonderful
spirit and that hard work is attractive
to people amazing yeah okay so
uh mr smart investor pro
you have to come clean now how much is
in investments
um it's
uh personally it's uh
60 or something like that but we we
actually
are a little bit behind on that because
we threw so much at the house and saved
to put a lot down okay but now we're
about four years five years from being
uh baby step millionaires
yeah now we're able to like
actually invest which is way more
exciting than paying off debt it's the
whole opposite side of the coin which
now i'm always talking her off now let's
do this and do this and it's not just
now it gets exciting
it's not just the pouring looking at you
know how quick we could get it paid off
type deal so i love it you guys are
amazing yeah congratulations i'm so
proud to have you as a smartbuster pro
anybody be lucky to have you advising
them and teaching them along the way uh
you're wise beyond your ears and you're
really really incredible so very fun
very fun excellent excellent excellent
so who were your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you
i would say
well each other and you just watching
your show
i go to the gym and i just watch your
show and i'm like oh i'm gonna keep
running because dave's show is awesome
like
you just are so funny i just i love your
show it keeps us motivated wow
very cool well you keep us motivated for
sure you guys are heroes very very well
done
very well done uh amazing start amazing
young couple rock stars good stuff good
stuff what was the hardest part for you
the chopping wood
keep chopping yeah it's the um
the sacrifices you have to make um which
you know
looking back weren't hard but you know
you just do things that our peers don't
normally do we might drive worse cars
than them and this and that and
but if you don't worry about that stuff
it doesn't matter so how many young
couples are willing to chop ten thousand
dollars worth of firewood cash flow a
wedding for anything for anything any
reason under the sun yeah i mean it's an
extraordinary story he used to park
around the corner when we'd go or when
he would meet with his clients because
his car maybe wouldn't start so he would
park around the corner and actually walk
to their house instead of uh
parking in their chair well you can find
a hill to get it on yeah well it was a
chevy impala it would start almost all
the time but sometimes it wouldn't it
was an ignition thing
it was a good car we had it for a long
time
yeah and some people think they gotta go
in debt for a car
to impress people and you just snuck
around the corner and getting great
financial advice they don't know yeah
and what i've found now like
my bigger clients and stuff like that i
could drive to a beat up truck to their
house because they don't know they know
me and you know that's all that matters
you know what they they know what the
beat up truck means too the big ones do
good stuff well done guys got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you number
one bestseller that is the next stage in
your
journey for sure the next part of your
story you're an impressive hero young
couple very very cool and of course a
copy of total money makeover you can
give that away to a client one of these
days if you want good stuff nick and
danny from norman oklahoma absolute rock
stars 75 000 paid off three and a half
years making 39 to 160. what a great
story count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three
two one one we're debt-free
[Applause]
oh my gosh there's hope for this world
just when you think that all the
youngsters are idiots you run into those
rock stars man
there is hope for this world there's a
whole generation of those people out
there that's right you old people we're
going to be okay that's christ
we got youngs like that coming on we're
going to be okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day hebrews 10 35
36 do not throw away your confidence it
will be richly rewarded you need to
preserve persevere so that when you have
done the will of god you will receive
what he has promised
james madison says the circulation of
confidence is better than the
circulation
of money ooh good stuff
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds for free free samples free
shipping new promos all the time always
use the magic word the promo code ramsay
to get the best deal blinds.com today's
question today's question comes from jc
in georgia i'm a 32 year old engineer
with a household income of 95 000. my
wife stays home with our four kids and
we are in baby steps four five and six
we plan on starting a side business this
year for me to do some home inspections
part-time depending on how well this
side hustle goes we've talked about
growing this into a full-time business
doing business inspections and
consulting in the future recently i
discovered that there are franchises
available for engineering consulting
firms doing this exact type of work
right now both the full-time small
business and the franchise are just
ideas that we're toying with that would
not happen for several years after we
pile up more cash and do research as we
think about and look into these
opportunities we want to get your advice
on buying a franchise versus starting my
own business would you prefer one or the
other are there major disadvantages to a
franchise that should make a stay away
or is franchising a viable option
uh i'm going to lean in on dave on the
franchise you know i know some friends
who are franchises or some of the
biggest names that you've heard of in
that space i personally would recommend
you start your own business the reason
is
because you have the experience and the
skill set as an engineer who's doing
very well right now financially being a
baby steps four five and six you're on
your way to being baby steps
millionaires if you're not already there
and you're starting this idea of doing
it on the side and i like that because
it allows you some flexibility as you
begin to kind of get in and test which
way do i want to go the home inspections
are great way to make money on your
schedule build up your reputation
i just don't think you need the
franchise this is my opinion to be as
successful as you want to be and can be
i think you can do it on your own and
it's a much better way to go it's all
yours you're making the call and you're
not having to upfront a bunch of cash
and buying into something else i
wouldn't go the franchise route that's
me there's two things you can get from a
franchisor
when you buy a franchise
one you can get national name
recognition
that you wouldn't have on your own so
you can open
dave's
subway shop right or you can open a
subway
subway shop right
um with the green and yellow and we all
know subway yeah all right or jersey
mike's sure nationally no
uh or mike could just open even if he's
from jersey right
but it's just a subway shop and when you
roll up in front the customer gets name
recognition they immediately associate
that
with a
cookie-cutter predictable experience
they know what they're going to get when
they walk in okay in the home inspection
world there's no such thing
there's not a national
name that says oh i always go to them
for home inspections
home inspections have largely been
mom-and-pop
situations or grown out of mom-and-pop
situations there's not a national name
the second thing you can get from a
franchise
is a
proprietary
uh trademarked copyrighted
uh process
or
access to use of a certain technology
for instance uh
in the uh quick sign business
there is some proprietary software for
cutting out the letters and getting them
onto those banners and getting them to
your office in three hours if you wanted
to have a banner that says happy
birthday at the office okay
that proprietary software if you're an
individual if you want to write that or
go build it
might take you
a bazillion dollars not millions but
hundreds of thousands of dollars lots of
man hours so you get a
a proven
process and or
proprietary technology of some kind that
gives you a head up you don't have that
either here there's no such thing here
so i'm with you i would not go with a
franchise in the home inspection
business there's not a proprietary
process there's probably some good
business practices that you could learn
but um basically you're going to pay an
upfront fee probably not a large one
maybe 20 000 bucks or something for a
franchise probably wouldn't be a big
it's not a 200 000 subway that's correct
half million dollar mcdonald's it's not
that at all or whatever mcdonald's costs
these days but the uh but but um
but but even though you're doing that
the other thing you're going to do is
you're going to pay
royalties a percentage of your gross
revenues for the rest of your life
and the success of this business is
going to be in your case 98 based on you
oh or the failures with contractors well
the failure's going to be 98 and even
the biggest most highly dialed in
franchises uh the success is still
40 to percent based on the operator
you've still got to go do the credit
yeah that's right you got to show up you
gotta do it with excellence you gotta do
it clean you gotta do it with a smile
whatever it is and so the operator still
matters and and so i'm not
anti-franchise but you need to analyze
what it is you're getting versus what
you're giving up and you're gonna be
giving up a percentage of your growth
and some upfront money for basically
some good business practices no i
wouldn't do it and in this situation you
look at the two sides he's looking at
dave on the home inspection if you get
connected with some great real real
estate professionals
you're gonna have all the
can go find you know engineers that own
uh that have engineering consulting
slash uh business home inspection
businesses in other cities
spend a day with them that's pay them
500 bucks yeah take a yellow pad or a
recording device and record everything
and ask them about eight million
questions about what works what doesn't
what's your biggest challenge what was
your biggest victory what's the dumbest
thing you ever did what's the smartest
thing you ever did you know how did you
get your best customers where do you get
them how do you get them what do you do
just ask a bazillion questions and come
home with a business plan really that's
correct and come home and hustle your
butt off and hustle and grind hustle and
grind you are the secret sauce for sure
in this setting most of the time that's
true in business anyway but it's for
sure true here no question so good good
question man that's a fun one to dial in
on jan's with us in lexington hi jen
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for taking my call i
appreciate it this is probably more for
ken um my husband and i are kind of over
our heads in this one of our children
is in a situation where she is separated
from her husband and children
by a distance of a thousand miles and
obviously you're divorced but she's
looking
to find ways to get closer to them but
is very satisfied with her position
she's a physician
and
we don't know you know we kind of
broached the idea of well is it
something that you could do remotely
because there are a lot of types of
telemedicine nowadays
and looking online we were looking at
indeed linkedin some of those type
things and it looks like yes there are
positions
but there's such a wide range of
salaries is there some general guide or
rule of thumb as far as
benefits
investment you know like things that you
put in retirements
do you get health care how does it work
if you work remotely yeah well
telemedicine
is
obviously a new development coming out
of the pandemic and the reality is is
that i don't think you have to help your
daughter that much with this this is a
physician she knows this world and what
she doesn't know she can quickly get the
answers to this i think the real issue
here is is is encouraging her and in
some way try to help her see that this
move is going to be better for her
relationally uh because it seems to me
the way i'm reading between the lines
here dave is we've got well should i
move closer to the kids should i not
telemedicine is it's a physician doing
the consulting over video it's not
here's the thing she is she is onto
something here and what she's on to is
that
more than likely in this remote setting
medicine or otherwise you're moving from
a salary position or an employee
position to an independent subcontractor
yes and so you're becoming self-employed
in some instances not every instance but
a lot of the work from home is basically
freelance right you basically move into
a freelance gig yeah in most cases i
mean not everything but a lot of this
remote stuff that is fairytale sounding
what are the red flags in 30 seconds
that you look forward here's what she
needs to be looking for she wants
instead of trying to do this on her own
we want to see if she can get in with an
established medical group or clinic of
doctors where they're looking for
telemedicine in those positions we're
looking for that we're looking to be
established out on your own
dependent contractor i wouldn't do that
with a divorce situation click and
mortar that's right not just click
that's exactly it's something that
hasn't established the roots and they're
looking for a specialist in this area
they're established good very good all
right and beware of stuff that sounds
too good to be true because it is it
always is yeah there you go
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you